a huge and important Easter egg not only
for the future of the MCU but the future
of the spider-man franchise may have
been spotted in Avengers endgame how's
it going everybody it's Warren and if
you weren't really trying to look for it
at the end of Avengers endgame you
probably missed this Easter egg an
Easter egg of the one and only Spider
Woman or Gwen Stacy or as she is
referred to in spider-man into the
spider-verse spider-gwen
so I'll break down the spider-gwen
easter egg in avengers endgame and what
it could possibly mean for the future of
the spider-man films and the future of
the MCU as well real quick if you'd like
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter my giveaway I'll be picking a
winner at 500,000 subscribers so again
if you aren't really looking for this
Easter Egg it's very very easy to miss
it's very quick it's very hidden and
it's at the end of Avengers endgame of
course since we are talking about
spider-gwen the Easter Egg for her is in
the Peter Parker slash spider-man scene
at the end of Avengers in game where
Peter returns to school and he sees Ned
if you pay attention to the scene and
you look really closely when Peter and
Ned are hugging you can see a blonde
woman walking by them wearing a pink
backpack and a spiderweb skirt this is
widely believed to be Gwen Stacy and it
makes perfect sense
before spider-man far from home came out
there was a lot of talk about Spider
Woman being in the movie and possibly
becoming a bigger character moving
forward and this definitely does
resemble Gwen Stacy's Spider Woman Gwen
Stacy's Spider Woman colors are white
black and pink and with the exception of
the denim vest that this woman is
wearing her colors are white to black
and of course the pink backpack plus the
spiderweb skirt is kind of a dead
giveaway as well after Avengers in game
came out it seemed very clear that
Marvel was heading towards developing
and a force now if you're not familiar
with who the a force is the a force is a
group of female Avengers and the comics
Captain Marvel for the most part leads
the a force which lines up with the MCU
we know that moving forward she'll be
leading the new team of superheroes and
not to mention we are now going to have
a Jane Foster Thor Wanda Maximoff where
the Scarlet Witch is going to be a
really big character moving forward you
have Valkyrie who is now
the king of Asgard and is apparently
going to be getting a queen and then we
have other characters such as nebula and
Gamora and plenty of other characters
and Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios himself has been supporting more
female character leads in the MCU for
some time now so it seems like we are
starting to get a set up for the a force
and who better to have in the a force
than Spider Woman and it looks like
Marvel dropped their first Easter Egg
for Spider Woman in Avengers endgame we
assume it's spider-gwen of course
because of the color she is wearing but
of course also to the massive success
that spider-man into the spider-verse
had where they introduced spider Gwen
who is now a fan favorite but of course
there is still a chance that it could be
the original Spider Woman Jessica drew
but let me know what you think about
this Easter Egg in Avengers and game do
you think that Spider Woman could be
possibly coming to the MCU soon be sure
to let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and of course don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain I like this video
and subscribe to my channel so you can
inter my giveaway and don't forget to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter as
well and of course as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof